wouldn't it be cool if you could film
yourself and easily turn into anything
you want like a cartoon character like
what is this could just be a means of
capturing performance and you can
visualize whatever your imagination
wants afterwards there's kind of No
Limits creativity is only accessible to
films or animations with multi-million
dollar budgets but it's part of our
Humanity to try to visualize things that
don't exist like let's talk about
traditional 2D animation cartoons the
most creatively liberated medium is also
the least democratized it takes
incredibly skilled people drawing every
single frame of your movie to make it
happen but I think we came up with a new
way to animate a way to turn reality
into a cartoon
it's one more step towards true creative
freedom where we can easily create
anything we want
so how do we do this how do we turn a
video into a cartoon well we've been
making a series of videos where we
experiment with AI image processing this
is similar to AI image generation but in
our case we are transforming images
rather than generating them from scratch
so one of the newest pieces of
technology is a machine learning process
known as diffusion at its core the
diffusion process lets computer generate
an image from noise much like how we
imagine an image from an inkblot or
looking at Clouds so if we take a
picture we already have and we put a
little bit of noise on top you can have
the computer clear up that noise while
drawing in new details that weren't
there before it's a lot like looking at
a picture and squinting your eyes and
trying to imagine you're looking at
something else and if you squint a lot
well what you're looking at becomes
really fuzzy and you can imagine that
you're looking at something different so
current technology can do this amazingly
with one image so why haven't we seen it
applied to video should we be seeing
mind-blowing visuals all over the
Internet fortunately the moment people
tried applying this to video everything
fell apart because the first step of the
process requires us to noise up our
image every single frame ends up looking
different and the video gets super
flickery the very nature of this text
seems to make it impossible to ever work
with video and well I nearly gave up on
using it but Dean here at the studio
kept experimenting and he showed that
with a little bit of VFX problem solving
this might be something that we could
actually overcome because at the time
that Dean and Fenner went out and made
that spider verse short and I set off on
a personal quest to use this tank to
enable me to make my very own anime so
it was time to Sherlock Holmes our way
through this and engineer a solution
this flickery problem in the first clue
was Jurassic Park
six months ago a user on YouTube named
hops uploaded an experiment he had
processed Jurassic Park to look like low
poly Zelda and he used an interesting
new technique to noiseify the image and
he had achieved excellent results so
I'll explain every time you process an
image the noise that you put on top
changes therefore the forms in the image
get changed every frame
if we freeze that noise Things become a
lot more solid in the image but now it
kind of feels like the image is moving
underneath a weird warp layer and the
details stay inconsistent so the new
trick used in that little Jurassic Park
video is simple if we can turn noise
into an image let's just reverse an
image back into the noise it would have
come from literally just do it backwards
therefore the noise is no longer
randomly changing every frame nor is it
locked if the two frames are nearly the
same so is their fuzzy noised up
versions and therefore they get
interpreted in their way so we had one
piece to the puzzle solved no more
random noise on our image but I tried to
make my video look like a cartoon and
every frame was being drawn with a
different cartoon style so we fixed one
problem just to encounter another
problem dead end well no because around
this time style models were becoming a
thing and the stable diffusion space a
person named nitrosock started creating
some amazing diffusion models built to
convert your image into one specific
style so then it dawned on us this was
the key to eliminating the style flicker
like imagine telling a hundred different
people to draw a cartoon dog you're
going to get a hundred different dogs
back now imagine giving everyone a
character style sheet saying draw a
cartoon dog exactly like this the images
are going to look a lot more similar so
we had to train our own model
specifically on only one style that we
wanted to replicate another big step
forward but it only uncovered another
new problem on tests I performed on
myself the features on the face were
still changing and jumping all over the
place so the idea us we made a video
where we trained ourselves into a
diffusion model so that we could tell an
epic fantasy story why not do that here
I train a model to not only replicate a
specific style but also specifically
know a character me I traded on images
of me wearing the same clothes on the
same green screen background that is
using for my test sequence and suddenly
boom everything locked in the
consistency between frames was hugely
improved well almost
it still wasn't quite perfect but we're
VFX artists who have worked with crappy
video files surely we must have a tool
in our Arsenal to deal with light
flickering so we applied the D flicker
plugin in DaVinci Resolve and we set it
to remove flickering light and it was
that simple suddenly we were there it
was working we had a consistent moving
emotive cartoon character and is all
just driven
with video of us on the green screen
I think we've cracked a workflow here
for getting something that looks like a
cartoon and it's pretty Bonkers it's
working you know I think we could do
maybe a couple more experiments but it's
like ready to rock I think Nico has
figured out the key to creating a
consistent character
so now it was time to make that anime
that I've always wanted to make because
as you've seen on the channel we have
our anime videos anime fidget Spinners
anime self-driving cars anime baseball
but they're all filmed for real because
we don't run an animation studio and
it's very hard to do so these days so
I've had this idea forever anime rock
paper scissors
what is the ultimate rock paper scissors
game two twin princes born at the same
time equal claim to the throne it must
be decided that day for the King has
died and rock paper scissors must happen
so we wrote this short film the next
step is to treat it like a cartoon which
means recording the dialogue first so
Nika who are you playing today I'm
playing flip and I have no idea how I'm
gonna what voice I'm gonna use I figured
that we would start and saying be like
yeah just go through a few lines and
then like we'll throw a filter or two on
it to help nail the vibe my character is
Jules my research here I just remember
the shot of Clint in here screaming into
a microphone I'm just gonna Channel
Clint today Nico has said that you go
you you whisper and then you scream and
there's no in between full Dynamics you
go really quiet and you get really loud
and you do full volume compensation on
there so it just sounds like somehow you
have this incredible presence where even
your quietest moments are as loud as
your screams so dni we did the voice
acting first and we just blew out our
vocal cords yelling as loud as we could
sure we did that we then designed the
costumes for each character basically
just went on Etsy and bought some goofy
clothes well look at this high level
um costuming here oh no we lost like
half the tape what we're trying to do is
you see these all these doodads here is
not gonna be great for the anime style
because this kind of intricate detail
wouldn't be included in the
illustrations because it would just be
more pencil mileage for the animators so
we're covering all that up with a color
that's similar to the rest of the
costume once this is put into the
animation space all this Jank gets
covered up with beautiful Illustrated
lines what we did on the green screen is
we basically imagined that we were
puppets right we're puppeteering a
cartoon character so we're posing like
the cartoon character and we're not
doing any audio recording instead the
audio is already recorded like a real
cartoon and we're out there just like
we're basically just puppets
because once again
are trying to treat it like a cartoon
so there's a specific way we have to
film this we're basically Gathering
assets obviously we're Gathering paper
cutouts that we're going to then pose in
our comic book A lot of these shots are
just us standing in a position and we
just need a single frame because a lot
of Animation is just single frames of
characters standing there against the
background while you hear dialogue and
there's a couple of rules that we've
discovered that we have to follow for
this so first and foremost you know the
style that we're matching it basically
has single Direction lighting it's not
like you have characters that are
painted with a beautiful Edge light and
a key light and a fill light in a
different direction for an under light
like to actually have to paint that
stuff onto a cell would be a lot of work
and so a lot of cartoons don't do that
they just stick to a basic light tone
dark tone shading system at most and
oftentimes it's just a single pink color
at the end of the day we get to take
risks we get to try things that might
break it because boy look at this giant
crew we have oh wait we have like two
people and an actor right it's like in
Hollywood you'd have 100 people on set
doing a big movie so we don't need
costume Department we don't need makeup
Department we don't need a crazy camera
Department right now we're just being
very very simple and very very
straightforward just focusing on the
concept Sam and I spent a lot of time
conceptualizing these shots because at
the end of the day anime is just really
all about tying your visual language to
the story and really getting into there
stylizing it thinking about things
metaphorically all that kind of stuff
once again it's your ideas that matter
right it's your direction your story
because the AI takes it the rest of the
way I love it it's such an awesome way
to work
hey guys so we are commemorating the
launch of this anime rock paper scissors
video with an awesome limited edition
shirt it's only available for the next
seven days available in tea and long
sleeve tea it's super cool it's designed
by human and once again it's seven days
only these are limited edition so snag
one right now also if you want to little
tip here come over here so subscriptions
to our website cost 3.99 a month but
subscribers get a 15 discount on all
merch so if you really want to get cool
you could go and subscribe to our
website and then use that discount and
then basically it's the same price plus
now you have a free one month of
subscription to our website just saying
don't don't tell anyone I told you that
this is between us cool all right so now
that I walked you guys through the
theory and the the techniques that we're
going to try to apply here let me show
you the workflow that we came up with
that led us to 120 effect shots for this
piece so here's the video of me on the
green screen in costume doing all the
acting with the lip sync right so what
we want to do is we want to have the AI
basically trace this to trace it in a
cartoon style so we need to train a
model to both know what I look like as
well as what style we want to apply so
when we were on the green screen filming
once we were done we also took a bunch
of pictures of me my face my body
different poses some full body shots
pictures my back different lighting a
picture of Nico paringer hey there I am
doing like the weird Fonzie point so
then we went and we took a bunch of
frames from Vampire Hunter D bloodlust
which is an anime that came out in about
the year 2000 it's actually free on
YouTube you can just go watch it if you
want to it's actually pretty cool and we
tried to grab frames like different
people some face shots some torso shots
full body shots Hands hair even some
abstract things like flowers because
with all these different objects with
each picture effectively being a
different object a different character
when we train the model it's not going
to learn any single subject instead of
going to learn the style in which all
these subjects were drawn one little fun
little thing here if you look at the
vampire hunterd data set you'll notice
there's no characters with full beards
there aren't any characters that pull
beards in the movie and this was a
problem actually when we first made the
model and it tried to represent me
sometimes out of a mustache sometimes
I'd have mutton chops it'd be all over
the place so I generated a bunch of
pictures of me some of them look good
most of them didn't but I took the good
ones and I re-added them back into the
data set and then trained the model one
more time I made a new one Nico
perringer in the style of Vampire Hunter
D
there it is it's me as an anime man and
notice it's got the the costume details
correct it's got my face features
correct my beard it's the same character
every single time at least consistent
enough every single frame so we got the
model done and now we can use this for
all the shots of me so I've just
received a fantastic plate from Nico
what I'm going to do now is take the
individual images and we're going to run
each one through stable diffusion to get
an animated character you have our
positive prompts which are vampunt D
aesthetic style cell animation of Nico
perringer man beard profile fist hand
but we also have this negative prompt
section which can steer us away from
certain things like detailed intricate
Lazy Eye Photography render CGI these
are all the things that we want to avoid
coming out and then basically there's a
bunch of freaking sliders and it's
really boring and there's all that stuff
that Nico goes into way more depth over
on Corridor digital.com because we don't
want to bog you guys down here with the
really silly specific stuff but there's
a bunch of processes that are laying on
top of that image to image process and
the output is this there is a really
cool animated frame of Nico there is
actually an interpretive element to what
the AI is doing there's blue shading on
the fur on his shoulders and basically
two-tone shading in his face it's a
really incredible process that we've
gotten way too used to at this point we
kind of forget how crazy this technology
is so what's great is that we can just
now run the entire image sequence with
this prompt and these settings it's
working really well but you know there's
a few janky frames like his head just
pops in for a second and then pops back
out little inconsistencies but they only
exist on a single frame basis you know
if only there was a way to kind of
remove a little bit of this Flicker and
smooth out this sequence into a nice
consistent character all right so Dean's
giving me this whole image sequence now
let's check it out
not bad it's a little flickery but like
it's consistent right you can see the
character you can see some of the mouth
moving all right so we take the shot I'm
going to pop it open in Fusion here and
resolve so the next thing we need to add
is the D flicker there's two different
modes one for time lapse and one for
fluorescent lights and if we turn on the
fluorescent light D flicker check out
the difference much better and if it's
not good enough here's how I fix it copy
paste paste paste
so now we have all these flickers turned
on look how stable my face and my
costume are the next step is just to
pull a green screen key and remove the
background and then finally reduce the
frame rate from 24 frames per second to
12 to look a little bit more like
animation and remove even more of that
flickering feeling now that we have an
anime man we need an anime world for him
to live in that's where Sam comes in
so very early on in the process we're
thinking how do we get consistency in
these shots we want one environment one
location so I'm using a environment in
Unreal Engine as the foundation for
everything and just like the video how
we're taking a video still frame and
then applying style to that I'm taking a
render from unreal and applying a style
to that that allows us to have
consistency we can go close up we can do
wide angles all the same objects in the
scene stay consistent here's our
Cathedral here I think it was called the
gothic interior mega pack The Moment I
Saw the screenshot of this environment
on the marketplace I knew was perfect
I've done a little tweaking redone some
of the lighting little modifications
here and there to make it match the vibe
a little bit better it is just bleeding
with sweet intricate detailed Gothic
style and it's just ripe for taking cool
pictures of I have a camera placed for
every shot in the piece and if we go
back out here look at that look at all
these cameras every single one of these
cameras is a different angle for
different background flights so shot 250
it's waste of shot maybe something like
here-ish yeah there we go so I'm not
even going to render these out with like
the normal renderer I'm literally just
going to take screenshots of this stuff
so screenshot all right it's a whip pan
so let's pan over
pan over Boop and maybe one more Just
for kicks all right so now I've gotten
four Images stable diffusion kinda takes
it from there let's go to my handy dandy
prompt sheet of all the different little
prompts I've tried out I believe this
one right here expressive oil painting
dark beautiful Gothic Cathedral interior
hyper detailed brush Strokes expressive
Japanese 1990 90s anime movie background
oil painting matte painting negative
prompts
blurry I'm all set let's take a look
all right so that's basically what the
process looks like for all these
background plates now that these
background plates are processed the shot
has everything it needs to get
composited basically an anime there's no
3D moves it's all either painted
backgrounds or cell animated characters
so we wanted to stay true to that so for
these shots we have a script that was
created by Nico that has everything we
need it's got lens Distortion it's got
clothes it's got light rays it's got all
this cool stuff basically we just drop
our foreground our background and the
final output it's pretty close to what
you want and you just go in and animate
little things and add a little bit of
flourish here you can see I have the
backgrounds that Sam made and I actually
just went into Photoshop and Blended
them together so you can see the edges
kind of smooth out I took those
backgrounds and I just literally
animated them scrolling past and so you
can see as well we've added some
directional blur some lens blur and then
we land on these two windows and do a
final little push in so once we drop
Nico on top of that you can see there's
this very Dynamic effect that's achieved
just by literally moving 2D images
behind them on top of that we have this
cool plug-in called light rays which
creates these beautiful rays of light
and we're using the plate of of Nico to
actually obscure those Rays so it really
marries Nico to the environment what
we're also adding to emphasize this
motion we took some of the 3D elements
of the candelabras from the unreal scene
we isolated them and we also turned them
into kind of animated candelabras so you
can see here as the camera's moving you
just whip a candelabra by as if it's in
the foreground to kind of emphasize the
idea that the camera is literally
orbiting around in classic anime fashion
to really emphasize the motion we bring
in these speed lines right here at the
end we have a couple more anime lines to
emphasize the point because that's a
very important character moment he's
challenging my character so all of that
together
with a little bit of lens effects and
then the final piece are these glows
which kind of emulate a film camera
because that's how anime used to be shot
back in the days animation cells would
be filmed through a film camera so we
try to emulate those glows and after all
that we get a sweet shot that I can send
back to Nico and he can drop it right in
the edit
one thing I want to talk about is a
democratization of of this process this
is a situation here where we're looking
at a piece of software that's free that
anyone has access to it process here
that we're sharing openly with everyone
because everyone's openly shared
knowledge with us with everyone and the
way this technology is developing I want
to be able to create really cool things
but the only way I can create really
cool things is with the help of other
people helping make the technology to
create those really cool things and so
since we've learned and are utilizing an
open source program with a lot of
contributions to people I want to give
back and I want to contribute our
knowledge and put it out there so that
you can go and make animations and
people can experiment and improve upon
the process helping all of us get better
so in this video I'm trying to make a
point of really going through the
process in a way that's interesting but
I'm not necessarily getting into a Click
by click tutorial for those of you who
want that we actually have that on our
website Corridor digital.com I'll have a
link in the description below and of
course with every support that's why
this video is even possible that's why
we're able to take you know four or five
people and spend two months just working
on an anime about rock paper scissors
it's thanks to all the support and the
members at corridorigital.com so with
practice because we've got this process
dialed in shot by shot we just started
getting faster and better and at this
point we are blowing through the piece
and it is working it's incredibly
exciting now most people in the office
haven't actually seen much of this yet
so we're gonna get wrapped up here with
the sound of music and all that good
stuff I'm gonna show it to them let's
see what they think let's see if we can
blow their minds
it's done
theoretically everything Dropped In
haven't washed yet just exported it and
everybody's gonna wash it with us I
think it's safe to say that most of us
here have not seen anything I've seen
one completed shot and it absolutely
blew my mind and I can't wait to see the
rest of it I have not seen it with a
sound design and that is what I'm super
excited for because Kevin sinzaki is so
good at what he does and man well I'm
here for Kevin damn right you are
foreign
[Music]
feels like a real anime in real life
and that's what it is there's like all
sorts of wacky AI Jank that Creeps in
but you're so used to it that it doesn't
feel like Jank anymore the the song that
Sam found for the ending Fenner made
this amazing shot where my fist comes
down and there's just this anime blast
that happens and then you just have this
drum roll coming
yeah it just all melts and then you just
get kind of lost it are we gonna get
another one Dean is coming
Vengeance at the end of all the anime
videos we always do one of those
montages of like and now here's all the
things that happen afterwards which are
like supposed to be like the end credit
joke but this one is the ultimate fast
forward a whole season in this montage
and like you know it subconsciously
makes you go oh yeah there's a whole
story here but we were just like
spitballing random shots
we get to do another one it's entirely
up to Corridor digital.com subscribers
we have a tutorial on how we do this
whole thing plus a whole bunch of other
cool stuff you want to check it out
support us help us make more stuff like
this
super cool you know this is a fun video
and all but I'm genuinely curious
oh brother
I'm proud of you though yeah I'll make
you proud would you dare one
in real life it happens at normal speed
okay one two three
one two three shoot
[Music]
okay